you've learn to implement deep learning
algorithms more or less from scratch
using Tyson and numpy and I'm glad you
did that because I wanted you to
understand what these deep learning
algorithms are really doing but you find
it lets you implement more complex
models such as composition areas or
recurrent neural networks well if you
start to implant very large models that
is increasingly not practical ways for
most people it's not practical to
instrument everything yourself from
scratch fortunately there are now many
good deep learning software frameworks
that can help you implement these models
to make an analogy I think that
hopefully you understand how to do a
matrix multiplication and you should be
able to implement you know how to code
to multiply two matrices yourself but as
you build very large applications you
probably not want to implement your own
matrix multiplication function but
instead you want to call a numerical
linear algebra library they could do it
more efficiently for you but it still
helps you understand how multiplying two
matrices were so I think deep learning
has now matured to that point where it's
actually more practical and you be more
efficient doing some things with some of
the deep learning frameworks so let's
take a look at the frameworks out there
today there are many deep learning
frameworks that makes it easy for you to
implement new networks and here are some
of the leading ones each of these
frameworks has a dedicated user and
developer community and I think each of
these frameworks is a credible choice
for some subset of applications there
are a lot of people writing articles
comparing these deep learning frameworks
and how well these people in frameworks
changes and because these frameworks are
often evolving in getting better at
month-to-month I'll leave you to do a
few internet searches yourself if you
want to see the arguments on the pros
and cons of some of these frameworks but
I think many of these frameworks are
evolving and getting better very rapidly
so rather than to strongly endorsing any
of the Australian works I want to share
of you the criteria on I would recommend
you use to choose framework
one important criteria is the ease of
programming and that means both
developing the neural network and
iterating on it as well as deploying it
for production for actual use by you
know thousands or millions or maybe
hundreds of millions of users depending
on what you're trying to do a second
important criteria is running speeds
especially training on large data sets
some frameworks will let you run in
training your network more efficiently
than others and then one criteria that
people don't often talk about but I
think is important is whether or not the
framework is truly open and for a
framework to be truly open it means not
only to be open source but I think it
means good governance as well
unfortunately in the software industry
some companies have a history of open
sourcing software but maintaining single
corporation control of the software and
then over some number of years as people
start to use their software some
companies have a history of gradually
closing off what was open-source or
perhaps moving functionality into their
own proprietary cloud services so one
thing I pay a bit of attention to is how
much you trust that a framework will
remain open source you know for a long
time rather than just being under the
control of a single company which for
whatever reason may choose to close it
off in the future even if the software
is currently released under open source
but at least in the short term depending
on your preferences of language whether
you prefer Python or Java or C++ or
something else and depending on what
application you're working on whether
it's computer vision or natural language
processing or online advertising or
something else
I think multiple of these frameworks
could be a good choice so that's it on
programming frameworks by providing a
higher level of abstraction than just a
numerical linear algebra library any of
these programming worlds can make you
more efficient as you develop machine
learning applications